Shannen Doherty shares new pictures at
showing the reality of her cancer battle
there's good days and there's bad days
and there's you know the chemo day and
and about four to five days after our
horrible horrible horrible days
the actress posted at two photos from a
recent chemo treatment she captioned
this first one what we call the red
devil being injected into me via the
port that's in my chest Don is my nurse
who takes excellent care of me
then this one her husband is sweetly
kissing her forehead while Shannon sits
and waits for her session to be over the
45 year old opened up exclusively to eat
tease at jennifer perros about those
treatments last month I have a bad
reaction to chemo and not everybody does
some people tolerate it quite well I do
not so I get chemo on Wednesday and I'm
pretty much sick until Sunday and Sunday
I can at that point I can just get out
of bed I live on Gatorade ice chips
thank God my husband figured that out
and so now we just have nothing but
Gatorade in the house stocks my husband
I could not have gotten through this
without my husband he's never missed a
chemo he's never missed a sick day